so National Geographic asked us here
tonight to tell you about a day in the
life of gelato monkeys and what it's
like to live alongside them for the past
decade the vet and I have spent years
living a loss on alongside this species
in a unique kind of alpine
out-of-the-way corner of Ethiopia but
before we get too far into monkeys we
need to start with geography because
this is the key to understanding the
species success and we're at National
Geographic after all so we kind of have
to start with this if we look at this we
have a map of Africa and you can see
this is an elevation map of Africa if we
just highlight the mountains in Africa
you'll notice a pattern emerges right
away they all cluster kind of into the
east you might think of Kilimanjaro when
you think of mountains in Africa that's
just a speck on this map 80% of all
mountains in Africa are located in one
country Ethiopia Ethiopia stands apart
it's the roof of Africa
so this is where Rebecca and I found
ourselves a decade ago living at 11,000
feet out of tents overlooking the Great
Rift Valley it was a big adjustment to a
new environment for us but there was an
even larger adjustment that we had to
make adjusting to an entirely new
society primate Society one full of
lovers quarrels tragic loss and their
never-ending obsession with food I was a
little bit dubious how this is going to
work out when I first got there but to
be fair the monkeys were a little bit
dubious about us at first as well but we
kind of grew into getting used to each
other to start off with this was never
part of my own long-term plan in fact
growing up as a kid I was interested in
a remote region a little bit further
north the Arctic I read a lot about
Arctic explorers and became interested
in how plants and animals can survive in
such a difficult ecosystem so as I was
finishing up my college program I
started looking for field jobs and I
came across one
that was relating to monkeys in the
mountains of Ethiopia I was like hmm
this is interesting this is a different
direction I'd like to know a little bit
more about this so I just sent off an
email to the other person that posted
the ad and I got a short you know kind
of terse reply back from a satellite
email account in this I was introduced
to the guava gelada research project
which was founded by doctors Peter
Fasching and Nia when to research
anthropologists based out of the US I
asked a couple questions I was like
what's the deal with this can you give
me some information I might like to
apply and so Peter wrote back he said
you know thanks for your interest this
is a position for no pay for one year so
we moved to a really remote part of
Ethiopia
the climatic conditions are pretty tough
here you won't have much contact with
your family and the food situation at
campus is kind of bland but and you
really sold this part we have a
solar-powered fridge that you can start
treats in if you really want but the
fridge is also full of fecal samples so
you have to really wrap them up really
well and it's very earnest about this
it's like okay well you know this sounds
kind of intriguing and then he had this
other comment it's beautiful here it's
like okay I think you've ticked all the
boxes maybe it's time for me to apply
and so he asked a couple questions of me
what kind of research experiences or
winter camping or whatnot do you have
that make you feel qualified for this
position so I grew up in suburban New
Jersey had never been camping before in
my life and I'd done a research project
on squirrels before in college so I
threw my best pitch together and you
know sent it off over the satellite
airwaves
and somehow a couple weeks later I had a
ticket booked to Ethiopia to arrive in
Addis Ababa a couple days after my
college graduation so a little insight
into my psyche at this time point in my
life was revealed well it's kind of
digging through all the emails to
prepare for this talk this is the final
email that I wrote to Peter
you know this PhD biologist that I had
never met before and I really wanted to
impress I signed off like this that's
about all for me I'm off the Taco Bell
for maybe the last time this year let's
hope I won't need that anti diarrheal
medication earlier than plan
regards Jeff I don't know what I was
thinking
seemed like a good idea at the time but
I really want to thank them for giving
me the opportunity to go to this place
and then upon a little bit further
reflection I thought maybe there's
weren't that many applicants all right
so in this in September of 2007 I joined
Jeff at the Casa where he had spent the
summer now
I had just graduated from college where
I'd studied physics and philosophy I'd
mostly spent time in the library in the
lab and like Jeff I grown up in the
suburbs at this point I also had never
been camping so as I was about to leave
for the field I sent Jeff an email
introducing myself and he wrote back
with really long lengthy replies details
about daily life at the Gua so full of
his thoughts and feelings he seemed like
he was pretty lonely up there we
arranged to meet at the airport in Addis
Ababa and he sent me a picture so I know
who to look for which he now knows this
so at this point I basically thought
Jeff was crazy and getting on that plane
I was actually pretty anxious about the
upcoming year but to step back for a
minute that summer of 2007 I had decided
more or less overnight that I wanted to
become a primatologist to spend the rest
of my life studying primates it was
because of this book by Robert Sapolsky
called the primates memoir where he
details daily life in the field in Kenya
studying baboons and all the colorful
field adventures that go along with it
but it really wasn't much of a stretch
from know who I am I really love animals
and I've always loved animals as a kid
visiting my grandparents in southern
India I would go out on the streets
kidnap baby cows like you see here
take them back to the house thinking
they were common property and on that
very same trip I actually had my first
experience with a monkey it was at the
temple that you see right here in
southern India and to make a long story
short I was closely observing a group of
monkeys when one ran up to the one that
was closest to me took its finger and
stuck it directly into the butt of that
monkey this monkey turned around
horrified and the first thing it saw was
me so I got bitten in the calf much too
my parents were I was hoping the
experience of glossa would be a little
bit better as I prepared to leave for
the field I sent Jeff a final email I
said you know you've been in the field a
couple months now you must be dying for
something from the u.s. to you know
remind you of home he replied I'd like a
single pack of rolos candy this confused
me I didn't really take it seriously I
said you know you want maybe five or ten
he said nope just just one I was
confused but I realized over time that
that's that's his Jeff so we lived
alongside these monkeys out of tents in
the Ethiopian highlands we live next to
farmers farmers who lived in farms that
neighbors Aguas oh that look kind of
like this there they grow wheat and
potatoes and barley and on our off days
we would be invited to these farms to
enjoy their delicious Ethiopian coffee
and injera here is Shoah and Ben toka D
su guys are brothers they've worked for
our project for about ten years now and
they've become really close friends
but at first they were pretty confused
about what exactly we were doing because
they see geladas every day they almost
see them as pests sometimes they said
you know why are you interested in
working with these monkeys why do you
follow them around all day and
relentlessly pursue their feces the
answer of course is that we are primates
humans or primates and by studying our
close relatives and their complex
societies we can hopefully better
understand who we are
and we also have a duty to protect
vulnerable species like geladas some
geladas today are confined to habitats
like this grassland that's been turned
into farmland so habitat loss is really
affecting the species and you can see
that contrast between the guava and this
picture here but now let's think about
what it's really like to be a gelato and
a gelato researcher and that starts in
the morning
[Music]
so a day in the life of a gelada begins
much as you might expect much as we
might begin our own days they slowly
wake up and roll out of bed except for
geladas their bed is a cliff on the edge
of the Great Rift Valley and they do
this because the cliff represents safety
for them that may seem a bit
counterintuitive but it's a place of
refuge from predators where they can
sleep
fortunately for geladas they have
incredible climbing abilities their
short stumpy fingers let them get up
these steep slopes without any trouble
and they don't seem to have any sort of
fear of heights I've seen juvenile
monkeys playing right on the edge of
precipitous cliffs without seeming a
care in the world and so that's how they
begin their day just with a big climb in
contrast researchers and photographers
we want to get to the cliffs before the
monkeys make it to the top that's when
the action starts happening so we wake
up a bit earlier in the pre-dawn chill
of the afro Alpine Highlands this means
waking up in the frost several days and
you know grabbing a quick coffee in our
kitchen tent and then hustling up this
hill
we start the day in winter clothing like
big puffy jackets and walking up the
field 11,000 feet you get tired and
start huffing and puffing really hard
and get covered in sweat a couple hours
later we'll be walking around in
t-shirts fighting off dehydration it's a
unique aspect of the mountains of
Ethiopia and any mountains in an
equatorial place where you get summer
every day and winter every night this
poses all sorts of challenges to plants
and animals that you know live in these
areas as well something from the
lowlands wouldn't survive up here so
we're surrounded by specialists and
among them geladas stand out as one of
the most charismatic so they climb to
the top of these cliffs and they bask on
the edges of the rim of the Rift Valley
for a while
adult males come up first they're a bit
bigger than the females and they have
longer fur coats so they can handle the
the cool Alpine air they'll just sit
there kind of stretch maybe yawn as the
Sun comes up and then they're followed
by the females and the juveniles they'll
huddle early in the morning when it's
cold to preserve one particular looking
out for their little ones
but pretty soon the whole herd is right
on the edge and their morning routine
begins so this involves you know running
their fingers through their hair sisters
cleaning other sisters looking for
little parasites that they'll pop off
and then pop into their mouths and you
know they're not just obsessed with
being clean this is a really important
part of their day to build social
capital with one another it allows them
to build coalitions that later when
monkey politics get a little bit complex
come in very handy juvenile monkeys
often imitate the older ones but get
some of the details a little bit wrong
I'm not sure exactly what this little
guy was looking for in there but I hope
you found it or maybe I hope we didn't
find it but they lose their attention
pretty quickly they'll do a little bit
of grooming and then they go off by
themselves to play so this may look like
they're fighting and it's a form of mock
fighting they'll bite each other and
tussle around in the dirt but again it's
them learning about how to act when
they're older any mistakes they make now
don't really have that big of a
consequence if you make the wrong move
when you're in adults however things can
be a bit more dire so we focused on the
visuals for the moment but geladas have
their morning routines in the auditory
environment as well so even on days when
you're totally socked in by fog trying
to figure out where the hurt is you can
just follow your ears hearing them
interacting with each other or you know
being conciliatory or sometimes a little
bit aggressive
[Music]
[Music]
so if these sounds seem a bit familiar
to you you're actually not alone almost
2000 years ago there was this
philosopher named Phyllis Sturgis
who wrote about the Sphinx monkey and he
described its voice now we have a
surrogate for Phyllis aureus here today
even the voice is similar to the human
except that it is not articulate but it
is like meaningless mutterings uttered
rapidly in rage or fear now Phil Sergius
also went on to describe the physical
appearance of the Sphinx monkey which we
again have filled surrogate for the body
is hairy as in other monkeys but the
chest up to the neck is bare it has
breasts like a woman and low reddish
protrusions resembling millet seeds
which surround the naked parts of the
body very prettily fitting in with the
human-like flesh color in the middle the
face is somewhat round rather like a
woman's so as you can probably guess the
Sphinx monkey is a gelato and even today
geladas continue to fascinate humans
they remain one of the most charismatic
and enigmatic primates maybe because of
the strange way they look and act or
those eerie similarities with humans or
their deep isolation in the ethiopian
highlands in 1938 National Geographic
actually had an article about geladas
the article called attention to that red
patch you see there on the right in the
hourglass shape this is what they
this monkey the name the bleeding-heart
baboon but the thing is that bleeding
heart isn't actually bleeding and
geladas aren't actually baboons instead
they're sit they sit poised on their own
isolated side branch of the primate
family tree and their own genus called
therapy focus the genus of grass-eating
monkeys if you were to go back into the
African savanna about a half million
years ago you would see basically
geladas the size of gorillas walking
around next to warthogs and zebras and
such but today only the gelato remains
and every day at the glossa these
qualities that make them unique compared
to other primates are on full display
so once grooming ceases in the morning
the day is warming up they make their
way to the high plateau where they start
feeding
geladas form the largest groups you see
in any primate up to fifteen hundred
individuals densely packed together the
reason that they can do this is that
they specialize on grass they're the
only grass eating primate because grass
is everywhere it's no problem to sit
right next to your neighbor when geladas
eat grass they pluck blade by blade
this might seem inefficient but they do
it with lightning speed and they have
really dexterous hands now geladas don't
have any special digestive anatomy the
way that say a cow does it allows them
to digest this energy poor resource
instead for them the secret is all in
the teeth now if your finger is clean
you might wish to reach to the back of
your mouth and rub your finger over one
of your molars you'll notice that it's
quite flat okay geladas on the other
hand had these huge rugged molars with a
lot of topography that act like scissors
to cut through this really tough
material our research at Wassa has shown
that of any primate geladas have the
most efficient chewing mechanism and
that's how they survive on this really
energy poor resource but iguazu with
this ecologically intact habitat geladas
eat more than grass
they snails and lizards roots and tubers
and the occasional pollen from the
red-hot poker flower so let's make our
way from the herd to the individuals as
they move across the screen they
probably look like an amorphous mass but
in fact there's some important
substructuring to gelatos the basic
social unit of geladas is the one male
unit this consists of one male like the
guys you see there in the back and
between two and ten females
this is his harem and this male has sole
mating access to all of these females if
females are closely related to each
other sisters mothers nieces and aunts
and like any family they they fight a
lot and then they make up we can also
now return to this picture you probably
surmise that those beads on the chest
aren't actually millet seeds but they're
just beads these are actually a complex
signal that the geladas are sending to
the males indicating they're ready to
mate the size and color of these beads
tracks the menstrual cycle so they
become more red and bigger until the day
of ovulation and then they get smaller
and paler like you see here in most
baboons this kind of sexual signal
actually occurs on the buttocks but
because a lot of sit on their butts all
day feeding it's moved to a more visible
place
[Music]